today on a star-studded game life it's
Belmont and blow I was like a buddy cop
movie it's exactly like a buddy cop
movie we are joined of course by and
blow and Veronica Belmont yes thank you
both for being here of course Jonathan
Boyle creator of video games such as
braid and the upcoming the witness your
new games gave me on the PlayStation 4
but it's also going to be on you know
the iPad so that people don't
necessarily have to get a console if
they if they want to get that experience
and PC as well and PC as well yeah yeah
and you know after those come out we'll
sort of look around and see what other
platforms even exist at that point like
you know a year from now I don't even
know what's gonna exist this is Apple
gonna build a television that is kind of
fast at running games and stuff right
Veronica is a tech technology journalist
somebody who's concentrating a little
bit more on the gadget space these days
what do you think everything that have
kind of heard about going forward all
seems to be largely cloud based and that
then goes to the same kinds of problems
he always on issues the you know the the
broadband connectivity issues even
bandwidth cap issues which I think you
know we haven't really brought up yet oh
right yeah that's gonna be a big if you
have a PlayStation 4 and you're
downloading the bulk of your games how
is that gonna work if you have a 500
megabyte bandwidth cap even yeah anyway
Gary's of broadband 2 throughout the
country you know that really that play
experience is gonna be or at least they
use the user experience is gonna be
pretty pretty effective Apple is
interesting because I mean they're
already they're already largely in the
gaming space in a lot of ways if they do
actually come out with a connected TV
that is built by Apple that works on
their ecosystem alone you know how many
people would would buy the witness for
that as opposed to buying it on a
Playstation at that point if they can
then have it in a large screen format
and also portable on their devices right
if it's cross play between all of their
devices independent of adoption of the
ps4 do you do you see iOS and the PC
versions as almost backstops to this
well I mean any of these systems could
be very successful right so you know we
we went toward PlayStation 4 on the
console side because it feels to me like
it could be very successful
but also just I want a lot of people to
be able to play the game you've been
talking here on the brand-new video
podcast for game life - John blow and -
Veronica Belmont guys thank you both
very much for being here thanks for
having me guys thanks appreciate it hey
guys if you have opinions about consoles
being always online or about indie
developers in the age of PlayStation 4
and iOS
leave them right there in the comments
or what's the next platform for the
witness to be developed for sorry yes I
think that watch that you have right
there that's totally this next Oh the
pebble version of the witness yep coming
excuse me 1 2014 guaranteed by Jonathan
Blow right here